foreign
if you had a 15 year old daughter who
claimed to be non-binary and wanted to
go by them they pronouns how would you
handle it
um it's in some ways trickier I was I
was thinking I think I said on air about
this uh
dad who responded to his daughter
claiming to be trans
by saying hey honey so am I and showing
up at school
bedecked in a gown and acting ridiculous
and the daughter got cured of that
delusion right quick because her father
embarrassed her so badly which I think
was just
brilliant
um exceedingly good dad mom work in this
case
yes such good dad mom dad work yep
um
but the whole Envy thing the whole
non-binary thing is
um
so trans is almost always in the modern
day and age uh especially in teenage
girls
um delusional it's it's it's social
Contagion
but it's con it's it's about move
becoming one thing from another thing
both of which are real mammals just
can't do that
non-binary and they them pronouns this
is entirely social construct Universe
there's like there's no there there
there's no no thing that you can be like
oh but like it's just it's just a
fantasy
um in every regard like I'm I'm neither
this nor that
but you know you are actually so I don't
I don't have a good like what I don't
know I mean the problem is you you know
you you need the actual child in order
to yeah the question yeah there's not
going to be a script you can't script it
right you can't script it I would say I
would not indulge the pronoun thing at
all even if your kid is trans
well in this case it's not trans
yeah non-binary
um that just means your kid's not good
at computer science but
um
not funny because computer science is
binary
I see
it was pretty good once you get by the
horrifying interpretation of the joke
and you get to the mathematical pretty
funny but um
I saw you briefly considered divorce and
then I saw you reject it for which I'm
grateful
um but uh
I I wouldn't engage the pronoun thing at
all right the fact is this is an
authoritarian move no matter what else
might be true of your kid the idea that
you are going to force a change in
language that is not a
um
that is a destruction of an actual
information carrying aspect of speech
doesn't make sense it's not it's not a
kid's right to do that
um
this is probably not exactly the right
move but I have directed a few people uh
who have people in their families
who were playing around in this space
um the piece that I wrote called what do
girls do
um and you know the answer is girls
become women that's what girls do and
some girls
um you know play in the mud and and
drive trucks and do math and some girls
have tea parties for their bears and um
both in both cases they're girls and
they become women because that's what
girls do so I do think a lot of the
social contagiony
um fashion stuff around trans and now
non-binary is actually thinly veiled uh
misogynistic regressive gender
stereotypes from earlier
so you know what does it what does it
mean to you to be non-binary uh does it
mean that you don't
um feel
like you want to become a woman like
this is an awkward moment
like some of the trappings of of
Womanhood are
not what you're interested in doing uh
okay that's cool you can do whatever you
want
should be like men can do whatever they
want in life all the options are open
and same is true for women
if what you're telling me is that you
don't like the changes your body is
going through
well that's puberty like that's
adolescence and uh some people have an
easier time with it than others uh but a
lot of people uh I I think especially
girls although maybe that's just because
that's what people talk about
um but you know a lot of teenagers
really struggle with the changes that
their bodies go through as they
effectively metamorphose right like it
would be easier if we had chrysalises
but that's not human right like we need
to continue to experience the World As
We Go From child to adult and that
teenager stage can be very very
confusing and especially in a world
uh that is celebrating
um is celebrating non-binariness and
transness and
um sending incredibly incoherent and
confusing messages about what it is to
be a man or a woman uh then you know it
doesn't actually surprise me this sort
of the newest the newest fashionable
thing that's that's ridiculous and so is
that and I don't want to do any of this
and I'm kind of not feeling like I want
to be in the sexual landscape at all so
this is what I'm gonna do like well but
that's not actually a category like I
know your friends say it's a category
but it's not like you are becoming a
woman and it's going to happen and uh
you can make of that any number of
things
and it doesn't it's going to be more
productive and amazing for you if you
don't obscure that behind some category
that uh that didn't even exist 10 years
ago
um I would recommend
that you as a parent listen to Jordan
Peterson's most recent uh Joe Rogan
appearance he goes through a dissection
of normal psychological changes that
girls face
uh and why that is fueling this
particular
bad
and I don't know whether or not I don't
know whether a kid could hear it but I
do think as a parent that having heard
it
will leave you somewhat better armed to
know what it is that you're confronting
in fact he talks about well but he only
talks about trans though I mean I agree
it's an excellent it's an excellent bit
of analysis that he does but this Envy
thing is different
I don't I'm not as compelled at that
because I think there's
true trans as we've talked about many
times then there's trans activism which
does seem to me like it is uh
escaping the same thing and so I'm just
not sure why the analysis of non-binary
and trans would be different it seems to
me it's exactly the same uh
psychological pathway that would lead
you there unless there was something
very specific going on
I'm not convinced but um still I think
you know he's he's a wise man and those
are wise words that he's got in that uh
most recent Rogan appearance
[Music]